I'm cannot wait for the hills reboot
like to it is seems like it's gonna be a
real good what can you tell me about how
filming has been going and hmm okay so
it the premiere is on the 24th and we're
all going to New York next weekend for a
week of press it's gonna be really
uncomfortable because the series there's
a lot of ups and downs there are a lot
of people that aren't talking and we're
gonna fight there's just so much drama I
mean in the first like ten minutes if
they're like showing what I think
they're gonna show it's just like a
kicks off so gnarly
yeah you need to stop having enemies
Spencer I'm sorry that you're making
yourself guys
you make them claims you don't consider
Spencer and Heidi family anymore is that
still the case
totally and I don't speak about non
family people that I've never met so
honestly there's yeah you'll see on the
show yeah you'll see on the show there
are reports out there that maybe you
could be painted as a villain this
season how do you respond to that I mean
I think everyone is a villain at some
point in a series I I take that on for
sure because the only thing I've bet on
the series is I mean drama for sure buy
it straight up like I've been living in
London and everyone is like no bull it's
not like LA like I love you frenemies
like London like when you have a problem
like you go for that person you're like
and you joined just like a loud bull and
like lies and like you call people loud
so I do that a lot so I might be the
villain I mean I fight with a lot of
people okay who do you fight with most
besides the people that we do not name I
can't tell you it's a whole storyline
yeah oh my god right up in the promo it
looks like you're sitting on Brandon's
lap he's so hot isn't he he's like 10
years younger than me though
so that's not a romantic thing well I
might find that out on the ship we'll
see ya are you dating right now are we
gonna see that part of your life you'll
see everything yeah it's weird being
back in front of the cameras in that way
does it ever feel I have to fend off
camera since the hills cuz I moved yeah
so I moved right when the Hills ended
I'm used to London
and I've been on a series there for five
years so when all the contracts and
papers for this was going on that was
like the first 11 months I hadn't been
on TV since I was 22 you're Pro I nice
to palm though like if I'm the villain
is just because I don't really give a
[ __ ] about all of your [ __ ] think
that also comes with age though right
you just decide I'm not gonna deal with
this I'm gonna be honest I'm gonna be
straight up that's just like an age
thing I think you would think I guess I
just like hanging out with children I
mean you'll see this area yeah have you
been with Mischa
I'm you'll see I don't want to give
anything away it's too good you know
ready start I feel like you and Audrina
are in a good place
I mean I've gotta go guys
[Music]